[Musique]
avec l'eau sont venus les anges de la
mort beau et cruel
mais par leurs meubles la farde
de nombreux hommes ont péri
[Musique]
une fois
touma
ça ne mène que v
venu à la maison de six heures voyez
qu'on sait pas ce qui se cache donc nous
croyez qu'on les entend pas
qui sait c'est adrien clauwaert c'est
une thaïlande heures ces armes nous
n'avons pas de runes
alors je suis votre rêve
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'une cache tu ne sais pas
quel point les questions tu poses
sondages
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est une
baisse de l'eau n'est pas l'une des
nôtres qu'est ce que tu fais là
ma place est ici c'est pas l'intention
de la liste des motifs arthur est ce que
j'ai l'air maudite d'après
je veux des ces vielles légendaire des
hommes les entendre
[Applaudissements]
il se doit dans leur moi tellement
[Musique]
puissant